Now, Galileo had his work cut out for him.
The idea that objects fall at a constant speed had been around
for almost 2,000 years by the time Galileo came around.
This idea had a lot of, as we say in physics, inertia. It is going to be very difficult to change.
If we were able to get the fact that feathers fall at constant speed,
Galileo had a pretty difficult task ahead of him.
Now Galileo had a proposal for why feathers do actually fall at constant speed.
He felt that some resistance provided by the air would actually slow objects down.
And for lightweight objects like feathers, this has a huge effect and causes them to fall
at more or less a constant speed.
Now, the rumors that Galileo's experiments involved him dropping
objects off of the leaning tower of Pisa—
it's quite possible that he did but it seems unlikely that he would have gotten good results
since, as we talked about before, the fall motion is just too fast.
Which brings us to the question--how can we slow motion down?
This seems like an essential aspect to doing any meaningful experiment with motion.
So, should we drop objects through water or some other liquid to slow them down?
Should we roll objects at inclined planes? An inclined plane is just another word for a ramp.
Or should we still drop our objects through the air but just
attached a parachute to them to slow them down?
I want you to tell me the best answer and there is only one here—so this may require some thought.
Keep in mind some of the points made over here when you're answering this question.